et nous sommes donc aujourd'hui devant
le château de chémery une demeure qui a
appartenu à alain souchon dans les
années 70 et depuis 35 ans est bien le
nouveau propriétaire s'appelle axel
fontaine un architecte de formation qui
le restaure pierre par pierre
une aventure humaine mais difficile que
la télé suit depuis des années on va le
retrouver dans un instant mais d'abord
les archives regarder elle date de 1984
ici se termine la sologne ici s'amorce
la vallée du cher chémery le château
dont on ne sait quand commence
l'histoire ou xiiie siècle certainement
ou un peu plus tôt mais sur le plan
pratique le fait que vous soyez
architecte de formation et de profession
ça facilite certainement les choses ça
facilite la compréhension du bâtiment
l'appréhension tout ce qui est intuitif
dans la façon d'appréhender le bâtiment
et j'ai essayé de continuer cette
profession d'architecte de la prolonger
jusqu'au stade de bâtisseur de façon à
pouvoir réaliser totalement les projets
et nous voici à l'intérieur du château
de chémery en compagnie d'axel fontaine
bonjour monsieur bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on va commenter
bien sûr ces images diffusées à la télé
en 1984 mais d'abord un mot sur
l'endroit où nous sommes installés
aujourd'hui alors landreau nous sommes
c'est la salle à manger du château donc
c'est une pièce assez importante parce
qu'elle a une fonction
elle a conservé sa fonction de salle à
manger puisque c'est là où nous servons
les petits déjeuners pour les nos hôtes
en table d'hôte et c'est également une
pièce qui sert au traiteur quand nous
avons des réceptions alors 1984 à
l'époque de ces images vous êtes
propriétaire depuis seulement trois ans
qu'est ce qui vous a pris pourquoi avez
vous un jour décidé d'acheter chémery
j'avais un ami d'enfance qui s'appelait
alain souchon qui était propriétaire de
ce château et c'est comme ça que petit à
petit la transaction s'est faite
pourquoi alain souchon at il décidé de
vendre le château de chémery alors
à l'époque
il commençait à être connu il avait
peut-être pas les moyens financiers
qu'il aurait permis de le restaurer et
commencent à être connues ne se sentait
plus chez lui puisque vous avez vu que
la route qui longe le château et à ce
moment là beaucoup de personnes venaient
tenter de l'apercevoir
allez on va regarder d'autres images
tournées cette même année en 1984
regardez
le vent coulis qui se faufile dans les
escaliers de calcaire et fleurs les
vieux fantômes du passé dans ces lieux
d'une autre époque pas ceux des vieux
rêves d'antan ils rejoignent aujourd'hui
parmi ces cheminée immense la
dure réalité de celui qui un beau jour a
décidé de tout abandonner ou presque
pour faire revivre les vieilles
murailles et qui jour après jour pierre
après pierre qu'il pleuve ou qu'il vente
envers et contre tous restaure comme un
forcené de l'amour vous avez commencé
par kwh à l'époque c'était quoi
l'urgence tout partout et par tous et
surtout l'ouverture au public qui était
assez simple en fait il suffisait de
disposer des panneaux pour signaler le
château après l'aménagement de notre
salle de réception des chambres d'hôtes
et tous emmena on a mené tout ça de
front la télévision régionale on l'a
bien compris et souvent venue filmer ici
à chémery regarder cet autre séquence
tournée un nom plutôt nous sommes en
1983 et vous connaissez ces personnes là
bien sûr c'est ma femme et ma fille on
abat depuis depuis on n'a pas arrêté le
jour il vit
les années se succèdent vous poursuivez
le chantier de restauration
il ya eu quelques péripéties à chémery
la télé on a souvent parlé
regardez cette séquence tournée au
milieu des années 90 précisément en 1995
et on en parle juste après chémery est
ce qu'on appelle un château de caractère
avec ses douves ses tourelles et son
pont-levis mais si ce dernier est
toujours ouvert les visiteurs
je ne rentre plus décision de la
commission de sécurité après une visite
le 8 décembre dernier dans la mesure où
il n'a pas été dangereux pendant 13 ans
je vois pas pourquoi il serait venu
devenu dangereux du jour au lendemain
sachant que depuis 13 ans nous avons eu
pour constant souci d'améliorer la
sécurité
l'épisode de 1995 n'était en fait que la
suite d'une accumulation de péripéties
voilà je crois que si on applique les
textes aucun chateaunet aux normes
donc il ya une volonté de nuire de la
commune
les ennuis se sont accumulés on en a eu
assez on à fait tranché par le tribunal
et on a gagné
vous êtes on a bien compris avec celle
fontaine un amoureux des vieilles
pierres vous est également propriétaire
de la tour beauvoir à blois
c'est le plus vieux monument de loi
c'est un donjon qui date de la fin du
xième siècle et c'est également la plus
vieille prison de france puisque aussi
devenu une prison en pressant 56 essais
reste une prison jusqu'en 1944
et depuis vous en avez fait quoi et
aujourd'hui j'ai eu plaisir à
transformer les cachots du rez de
chaussée en cachot d'hôtes
donc on peut dormir en prison dans deux
réseaux en dehors avec des barreaux aux
fenêtres on dort avec des barreaux aux
fenêtres bientôt je vais installer des
chaînes parce que tout le monde me le
demande
une toute dernière question sur chémery
la restauration ici ces avis j'espère
bien oui oui oui j'espère ne pas finir
parce que finir si mourir et je crois
que je serais prêt à partir pour un
autre
merci infiniment axel fontaine de nous
avoir reçus chez vous à chémery et
l'ours dit à bientôt pour retrouver la
mémoire